this is why the U.S president's visit to
Northern Ireland is so significant
[Music]
Joe Biden is here to recommit America to
preserving The Fragile peace in Northern
Ireland the United States has played a
significant role in The Journey from
conflict it was former President Bill
Clinton who helped facilitate the IRA
ceasefire and his Envoy Senator George
Mitchell who brokered the Good Friday
agreement 25 years ago
[Music]
President Biden won't be in this corner
of the United Kingdom for very long he's
not going to Parliament buildings at
Stormwind because there's no power
sharing government there at present
instead he'll address an audience at
Ulster University an indication perhaps
that he believes it's up to the Next
Generation to make the hopes of the Good
Friday agreement a reality
[Music]
The Good Friday agreement was a historic
compromise between unionists and
nationalists they agreed that Northern
Ireland would remain part of the United
Kingdom until a majority here voted
otherwise they also agreed to share
power in government and terrorists
agreed that they would destroy their
weapons
[Music]
there's a difficult political situation
in Northern Ireland right now the
Democratic unionists are boycotting the
power sharing government over the brexit
Border in the Irish sea Joe Biden will
call on all sides to restore that
government as soon as possible not least
because the Threat Level here has
increased from substantial to severe